[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et à toutes merci à vous
tous et à vous tous d'être là je
voudrais aujourd'hui vous parler de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation de la
trajectoire de nos systèmes
réglementaires et de notre pouvoir à
tous de le changer
je pars d'un constat c'est que depuis 40
50 ans peut-être nos systèmes
agroalimentaires ont mis l'accent sur
l'augmentation de la production dans une
démarche qu'on peut dire productiviste
quantique avis quantitativiste visant à
augmenter de volume et ses options qui
ont été prises dans les années 60-70 la
politique agricole commune a été lancée
en 1961
ces options pouvait s'expliquer à
l'époque par le souci de garantir la
sécurité alimentaire dans un monde où la
croissance démographique était encore
très importante
aujourd'hui cependant les choix qui ont
été faits dans les années 60 et 70
produisent des conséquences
problématiques qui n'est plus possible
d'ignorer cette économie alimentaire low
cost s'est développée à partir de l'idée
qu'on pouvait rémunéré faiblement le
producteur sauf par des subsides qui
compense le manque à gagner sur la
production payer des salaires très bas
aux travailleurs agricoles ne pas
obliger des producteurs à internaliser
les externalités négatives sociales
environnementales sanitaires qu'ils
causent
on a développé une économie alimentaire
low cost qui visaient à garantir l'accès
à une alimentation bon marché y compris
pour les ménages les plus pauvres mais
des conséquences problématiques vous
disais ans ont résulté conséquences
environnementales d'abord le
développement de grandes monocultures
qui a détruit la biodiversité qui a
conduit à l'augmentation considérable
des gaz à effet de serre les systèmes
alimentaires c'est 33 % des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'origine humaine à
l'échelle mondiale une destruction des
sols qui ont subi avec ces monocultures
de l'érosion de la compaction ollier a
utilisé son et grande machine la
salinisation des sols liée à des
mauvaises techniques d'irrigation
agricole et puis
des conséquences sociales nous avons vu
partout disparaître les petites
exploitations agricoles dite familiale
en belgique depuis trente ans on a perdu
près de deux tiers de nos fermes les
plus petites les moins compétitives
disparaissent dans un marché de plus en
plus concurrentiel et enfin des
conséquences sanitaires puisque nous
développons ces grandes cultures pour
fournir des matières premières à
l'industrie de transformation
agroalimentaire qui dès lors et coule
sur les marchés des plats préparés des
produits transformés ultra transformer
expliquant l'explosion dans le monde des
taux de surpoids et d'obésité avec les
maladies non transmissibles qui sont
liées diabète de type 2 maladies
cardiovasculaires cancers
gastro-intestinaux
voyez par exemple cette étude publiée
dans le lan 7 en 10 ans en 2016
à partir de 200 pays 19 millions de
personnes ont été suivies au cours de
trente ans et entre 1975 et 2014
l'obésité partout à augmenter alors nous
dit parfois que cette approche
productiviste elle sert à satisfaire les
besoins du monde il faudrait que
l'europe par exemple nourrissent les
pays en développement
augmentant sa production pour répondre à
la capacité d'autres pays de se nourrir
eux mêmes mais en réalité ces pays se
plaignent de ce que leurs marchés sont
envahis par des produits alimentaires
bon marché fortement subsidié par les
contribuables des pays riches et cette
photo qu'un jour il ya un
arthus-bertrand a prises et qui m'a
demandé de commenter un jour illustre
cela sur le mode de la métaphore on voit
ces produits fortement transformer en
ballet s'écouler sur les marchés des
pays en développement faisant
concurrence aux petits producteurs
agricoles de ces pays là alors oui il
faut changer il faut changer mais le
système est inerte il est difficile à
réformer
et ceci parce que ce système est composé
de différents éléments qui ont co évolué
et qui aujourd'hui se soutiennent
mutuellement
des choix techniques ont été faits aux
technologiques ont investis en
infrastructures en logistique pour
favoriser des économies d'échelle la
production de masse
on a fait émerger par conséquent des
grands acteurs
les champions de l'économie alimentaire
low cost du côté des acheteurs de
matières premières des entreprises de
transformation agroalimentaire et du
côté des grands distributeurs
ceci s'inscrit dans des modes de vie de
plus en plus pressée où l'on n'a plus le
temps de cuisiner des produits frais
venu de producteurs locaux ou d'ailleurs
on perd les savoirs culinaires et ceci
contribue à renforcer le pouvoir d'
influence politique des grands acteurs
de l'agroalimentaire ces grandes
entreprises qui dominent aujourd'hui les
systèmes agroalimentaires et demande au
gouvernement de développer des
infrastructures des logistiques un
système économique qui va renforcer
encore leur puissance dominante
par conséquent notre manière de nous
alimenter les modes de vie que nous
avons développé notre rapport à
l'alimentation et la cuisine sont co
responsables de cette situation dont à
présent nous sommes victimes
alors ça explique que beaucoup de
citoyens de citoyens ordinaires se met
en mouvement pour rechercher des
alternatives au système dominant
on va se développer par exemple des
fermes urbaines comme ici au chant des
cayes à boitsfort on voit se développer
des chaînes direct de distribution
reliant les producteurs locaux aux
consommateurs par exemple à travers le
réseau des groupes d'achats solidaires
de l'agriculture paysanne à bruxelles
les groupes d'achat commun en wallonie
où les milliers d'âmes ap
les associations pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne en france on voit
se développer des initiatives à travers
lesquelles les organisations caritatives
qui viennent en aide aux ménages
défavorisés utilisent les invendus de la
grande distribution pour les fournir à
ces familles très pauvres
on va se développer des supermarchés
coopératif sur le modèle souvent de la
park slope foule coop créé à brooklyn
dans les années 1970 et qui mitent
aujourd'hui la biz coop
par exemple à bruxelles tout ceci est
important
tout ceci est important et au fond on
montre qu'on peut sortir de notre
position de consommateurs critiquent ou
des lecteurs responsabiliser à l'écouté
des messages des partis politiques ce
sont des acteurs véritable qui cherchent
à inventer des alternatives
mais la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
est de savoir si au fond nous ne sommes
pas dans une sorte de dilemme d'impasse
est ce que ces alternatives ont demeuré
à l'état de deux niches d'innovation ou
bien vont être coopté par le système
comme parfois certaines filières bio
certaines marques de commerce équitable
est-ce que l'alternative est vraiment
entre la préservation de ces initiatives
à petite échelle ou la capture par le
système dominant qui pourra en cooptant
ces alternatives au fond s'acheter
toujours un peu plus de temps pour durer
pour continuer de dominer je voudrais
pour ma part que nous imaginions comment
sortir de ce dilemme et je ne vois pas
d'autre possibilité que d'encourager la
démocratie alimentaire qu'à côté de
saisie alternative qui se développe à
travers les chaînes courtes à travers
des marchés paysans à travers les
supermarchés coopérative long politise
la question de l'alimentation et ça se
fait de plus en plus en californie on a
développé un conseil de politique
alimentaire et ses conseils de politique
alimentaire ces forums citoyens où se
réunissent les différents acteurs des
systèmes alimentaires pour réfléchir
comment transformer le système
alimentaire se développe partout au
canada aux états-unis au royaume-uni
ici dans la ville de cork par exemple
dans le sud de l'angleterre
ces citoyens ont compris qu'il ne
suffisait pas de consommer de mal
critique de voter pour les bons partis
ou même de devenir acteur de systèmes
alternatifs
ils ont compris qu'il fallait exercer le
pouvoir non pas prendre le pouvoir mais
exercer le pouvoir en se mettant
ensemble pour imaginer des alternatives
au système dominant au fond leur devise
celle par laquelle je voudrais terminer
leur devise c'est que la seule véritable
limite à notre pouvoir
c'est que nous n'osons pas les l'exercer
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]